la vanne aujourd'hui tout est paisible
comme d'habitude et rien ne laisse
croire que ce quartier résidentiel est
désormais une zone à risque pour les
diplomates canadiens le poste de
diplomate sera un poste non accompagnés
c'est à dire sans famille comme c'est le
cas à kaboul et tripoli
car c'est ici dans la capitale cubaine
qu'il ya près d'un an des diplomates
canadiens et américains auraient été la
cible d'une mystérieuse attaque qui leur
auraient causé des symptômes de
commotion cérébrale à ottawa la députée
du parti démocrate et ex diplomate réagi
vivement à cette histoire
ce que je trouve de pas rassurant c'est
le fait on est traité les gens qui ont
été affectés comme ça les membres du
corps diplomatique et leurs familles
qu'on les aime ou qu'on leur pote donner
plus de puissance
aujourd'hui le gouvernement réitère
qu'il a à coeur la santé de ses
représentants à l'étranger va santé la
sécurité de nos employés de leur famille
de priorité au canada
à nous continuons de travailler
avec les autorités cubaines ainsi que
les autorités américains jusqu'ici rien
ne ressort des enquêtes de la grc et du
fbi haye de concert avec les autorités
cubaines
on n'a pas vu des centaines des nouveaux
cinquième depuis l'été dernier et on a
travaillé de ce temps là pour mieux
connaître la situation et pourquoi ces
symptômes ont été subies mais selon nos
sources le dernier cas de diplomates
avec des symptômes de commotion
cérébrale remonterait à décembre 2017
si les gens qui sont revenus avec des
complications ont peu été traitées
adéquatement on peut reçu un niveau de
service comparable on est obligé d'aller
aux états unis pour se faire prêter
comme les diplomates américains se
faisait traiter ballon se demande qu'est
ce qui arrive avec le res ces
pourritures 24 diplomates américains
touchés par cette histoire ont été
examinés par une équipe médicale de
l'université de pennsylvanie
on ignore toujours aujourd'hui si ottawa
permettra aux diplomates canadiens
d'être examiné par la même équipe ici à
des bodegas radio canada montréal